Say, kids, would you like to hear a story?
Cause we’ve got a really good one for you.
Seriously.
You're going to love it.
It's a classic rags to riches tale, about
one man's rise from humble beginnings to becoming
one of history's greatest and most visionary
toymakers.
Or maybe it isn't, maybe it's about a company
that literally came from nothing, whose origins
are still shrouded in mystery.
Maybe it's about a woman breaking the glass
ceiling to take over the toy company left
to her by her eccentric father.
Maybe it's about all of these things, but
the one thing we can tell you about the story
of Dr. Wondertainment is that every word of
it is true.
Or at least, as far as anything is true in
the weird, wonderful world of the SCP Foundation.
As long as you believe, we’ll all have a
wonderful time.
As long as you believe, nothing can hurt you...Not
in the fabulous world of Dr. Wondertainment!
Dr. Wondertainment is the name given to SCP-001,
who due to his relatively benign nature, has
been classed as Safe by the Foundation.
Rather than focusing on containing Wondertainment
himself, the SCP Foundation has centered its
efforts on containing the products that he
creates.
He is a Class-1 reality warper, capable of
constructing otherwise normal objects and
imbuing them with anomalous properties.
He's become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre, magical, and potentially
dangerous toys and games that are distributed
by as-yet unknown means.
Many of Wondertainment's
toys are in the Foundation’s
possession, such as SCP-445, origami paper
that takes on properties of whatever it's
folded to look like, and SCP-3147, lollipops
that allow people to switch voices with each
other.
Dr. Wondertainment was born into a family
of humble means.
His mother was a seamstress and his father
was an accountant.
Unsatisfied with his mundane
life, Wondertainment's
only joy growing up was in the stories that
his father would tell him about an ancestor
of his who was once a famous toymaker.
Inspired by these stories, Wondertainment
developed an interest in crafting toys, and
as an adult, set out to learn the secrets
he would need to create toys unlike anything
the world had ever seen.
He spent his life following rumors of magical
artifacts and enchanted trinkets, until his
search brought him to a mysterious factory.
If you've seen our previous videos on SCP-001
proposals, you can probably guess that this
factory was The Factory, the mysterious place
where new SCPs are supposedly created.
Wondertainment barely escaped the massacre
and the Foundation takeover of the Factory
with his life, but he was able to find a variety
of notes that he took with him.
These notes contained clues that led him to
the workshop of his famous toy maker ancestor,
and from there, he reclaimed his birthright.
That was the day that he truly became Dr.
Wondertainment.
It's a fun story, isn't it?
Very straightforward.
But perhaps it's a little underwhelming for
an SCP-001 proposal.
After all, SCP-001 is the collective designation
given to some of the most important anomalies
of all time - including many that could have
potentially been involved in the Foundation’s
very founding.
Let's start again.
Reginald Philbert Lionel Archibald Westinghouse
Wondertainment III is the name given to SCP-001,
who, due to his highly unpredictable nature,
has been classed as Euclid by the Foundation,
and he is to be detained as soon as his location
can be ascertained.
Until he can be captured, the SCP Foundation
has focused its efforts on containing the
products that he creates.
He is a Class-2 reality warper, capable of
constructing otherwise normal objects and
imbuing them with anomalous properties.
He's become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre, magical, and potentially
dangerous toys, games, candy, soft drinks
and other products aimed at children and young
teens.
These products are distributed by as-yet unknown
means.
Many of Wondertainment's creations are in
Foundation possession, such as the often imitated
but never matched Little Misters collection,
which are a group of living collectibles with
unique anomalous properties.
Due to Wondertainment's reality-warping abilities,
it's impossible to pin down concrete information
about his history.
What we can tell you for sure is that he's
immortal, and ageless, and comes from a long
line of Wondertainments stretching all the
way back to the Cretaceous Period, where they
made all sorts of toys for the good little
dinosaur children.
It's also widely known that he is in fact
not a real person, but merely the manifestation
of the dreams of every child on earth, brought
forth solely by the power of imagination.
No confirmed sightings of Dr Wondertainment
have ever occurred, but witnesses have described
him as “dashing”, “very handsome for
his age”, and a “lovely chap, capable
of creating whimsy and wonder with the snap
of his fingers.”
He's a tall man, about the height of a piece
of string, and he's immediately recognizable
by his walking stick and W-shaped moustache.
It's also been reported that he has scarring
around the circumference of both wrists, almost
as if his hands had been removed and reattached
at some point.
However, the truth of the matter is that-
Hm.
No, no, we're telling it all wrong again.
This doesn't do anything to capture the scope
of the Wondertainment story.
It needs to feel bigger, more comprehensive.
Let's try it again.
Dr Wondertainment is a
trademark of the Wondertainment
Toy Company, the name given to SCP-001, a
corporation that, due to its consistent output
of anomalous items, is classed by the Foundation
as Keter.
Until this company can be permanently shut
down, the SCP Foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that it creates.
The collective power of the company's constituent
employees and the technology they make use
are equivalent to that of a Class-3 reality
warper.
The Wondertainment company produces and sells
a range of products, ranging from the seemingly
normal to the downright weird, all imbued
with anomalous properties.
The company has become infamous for their
constant output of bizarre,
magical, and potentially
dangerous toys, games, candy, soft drinks
and other products aimed at children, teens,
and young at heart adults.
These products are made and distributed from
Wonder World - trademark - a location that
is as-yet unknown to the Foundation but offers
factory tours every hour from Tuesday to Friday.
Many of Wondertainment's creations are in
Foundation possession, such as Wondertainment's
famous Dragon Snails – the real fire breathing
pet you can keep in your pocket!
Not much is known about the inner workings
of the Wondertainment company.
The SCP Foundation has no information currently
on the company's leadership structure, location,
history, or corporate policies.
Various former and current employees have
been interviewed regarding their experiences
working for Wondertainment, but they never
seem to be able to remember very much of use.
Those interviewed variously
describe the Wondertainment
company as a regular office building, an immense
toy factory, an amusement park, but all agree
it's the best place they've ever worked!
In fact, you should apply for a job there!
We- I mean- they- have a few openings in their
legal department....or so I've heard.
Oh, silly me, it seems we've gotten off topic.
You're here to hear about the SCP-001 proposal.
Posting a job ad wasn't what I meant to do
when I hacked into- I mean, well… don’t
worry about that.
Forget I said a thing.
Now, let's try this again, but this time,
we'll add a twist.
Isabel Helga Anastasia Parvati Wondertainment
the Fifth is the name given to SCP-001, who
due to her ability to spread sunshine and
whimsy wherever she goes, has been classed
as Thaumiel by the Foundation, and due to
her immensely unpredictable nature, the SCP
foundation has resolved to just leave her
be.
Because she can't be captured, the SCP foundation
has focused its efforts on containing the
products that she creates.
She is a Class-4 reality warper, capable of
constructing wonderful, fun-tastic objects
and imbuing them with anomalous properties.
She's famous and widely beloved for using
this ability to create bizarre, magical and
not even a little bit dangerous toys, games,
candy, soft drinks and other products aimed
at everyone from ages 9 to 99.
These products are distributed by as-yet unknown
means.
Many of Wondertainment's creations are in
Foundation possession, such as SCP-3551 - the
awesome inflatable alien invaders, and SCP-2514,
a lovely horse who can sing Happy Birthday!
How grand!
Wondertainment inherited the Wondertainment
name from her father, who either passed away
or never existed at all.
The circumstances of his death and perhaps
non-existence were very messy, involving a
mass murderer, the leader
of a shadowy international
extra-governmental paramilitary organization,
at least one deity, and four bent paper clips.
She owns six corgis, and all of them are named
Jeremy.
In her free time, she likes to-
No no, this is still wrong.
Alright, enough is enough.
You want to know who Dr. Wondertainment really
is?
Well, you asked for it.
Dr. Wondertainment is the name given to SCP-001,
who due to his deity-level power, has been
classed as Apollyon by the Foundation.
There is no possible way to contain him.
He is a Class-5 reality warper, capable of
breaking down and reconstructing the very
laws of reality.
Did you really think that those little trinkets
were the full extent of my...
I mean his creations?
Did you truly think of him as such a small,
petty creature?
Dr. Wondertainment is no mere toysmith…
No, he is a god.
Want examples of his creations?
Just look around you!
Everything from the most innocent Safe-class
to the most harrowing Keter-class, it's all
thanks to him.
He's behind everything!
Marshall Carter and Dark, the Sarkists, The
Church of the Broken God, even the Scarlet
King himself!
All that time, all that effort, all it came
down to was one entity, one singular living
personification of chaos.
One day the SCP Foundation will finally give
up trying to find out how he distributes his
products, when they will finally see how small
and worthless their attempts to restore order
really are.
AND THEY WILL BE DRIVEN BEFORE HIS POWER,
THEY WILL CRUMBLE AND DECAY INTO NOTHINGNESS,
YOU WILL BOW BEFORE DR.
WONDERTAINMENT!
Had you going for a second there, didn't we?
You should've seen the looks on your faces.
But let's start again, one more time.
We're being serious this time.
Mask off, here's the true
story of Dr. Wondertainment.
Dr. Wondertainment is the name given to SCP-001,
who due to his relatively benign nature, has
been classed as Neutralized by the Foundation.
Rather than focusing on containing Wondertainment
himself, the SCP foundation has focused its
efforts on containing the products that he
creates.
He is a reality warper whose limits have yet
to be documented, capable of constructing
otherwise normal objects and imbuing them
with anomalous properties.
He's become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre, magical and potentially
dangerous toys and games that are distributed
by as-yet unknown means.
Due to his secretive nature, almost nothing
is known of Dr. Wondertainment's true origins,
and the waters have been muddied extensively
by the side effects of his reality-warping
ability.
In fact, it's entirely possible
that Dr. Wondertainment
himself doesn't know who he is anymore.
It's possible that all the proposed origins
and descriptions of Dr. Wondertainment are
true in their own way, but it's equally possible
that none of them are.
All that's
known for sure is that Dr. Wondertainment
- be they male or female, corporation or single
individual - is a constant thorn in the SCP
Foundation's side.
No matter what they really are, they’re
not going away soon, and only time will tell
who they’ll be tomorrow, or what further
horrors they and their company will create.
And that’s where our story will have to
come to an end.
At least, for now.
We hope you enjoyed it, and remember: Keep
believing.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Which is the
Real 001?” and “SCP-001 - The Children
- Ouroboros Cycle” for more knowledge on
the mysterious and elusive SCP-001!